[Music]
logan is gonna wake up
on an airplane
him and the whole squad like
like chained up in their first class
seats
and this dude's gonna be walking up the
aisles
and he's gonna be like
just holding the pilot hostage with a
serrated blade
he's like now logan
we got the gang on here
we're all we're like this yeah we're all
like this dude aren't we
come on say it we are right
someone's got to get us home
and we're going down as we speak
so who wants a pilot
logan's like
you need a pilot logan to bring us home
pilot's like
[Music]
oh jeepers he wasn't part of our gang
though was he logan
neither was everyone else in the back so
i took care of it you look down the
aisle the whole second
passenger oh my god look
logan just starts crying he's like
trying to get out of the thing what's
wrong logan you're a good looking guy
you got nothing to worry about
so tell me logan can i have a job now
you want to hire me to fly the plane
logo's like yes yes yes
you can slide the plane
too late and just run straight into the
[ __ ] i don't know how to fly runs up
to the escape hatch
runs down the aisle opens the door just
goes out
now it's logan mike and all the podcasts
being like
papers flying everywhere
dead the dead bodies a [ __ ] coach
just
right
just
not first class
just getting all piled up in the door
just
it's too many
trying to squeeze out that
then logan wakes up
[ __ ]
lays back down and then sleeping right
next to him have a bad dream
holy [ __ ] man